[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi presento Mi chiamo Teresa capparelli
e Sono una psicoterapeuta sono e non
faccio benché provi a tracciare dei
Confini per non identificarmi con il mio
lavoro perché sapete essere una
psicoterapeuta quando si ha sperimentato
un disturbo d'ansia per molto tempo non
è affatto semplice
quello che i pazienti portano a dispetto
di quanto si immagini fa un gran rumore
dentro di sé e a dirla tutta alle volte
Attiva anche il proprio
per fortuna Esiste la psicoterapia il
mio compagno me lo dice sempre voi
psicoterapeuti esistete per sostenere
altri psicoterapeuti i quali ne
sostengono altre ancora in un circolo
senza fine poi dicono che noi psicologi
non lavoriamo eh
faccio la psicoterapeuta dicevo e ho
avuto un disturbo d'ansia per molto
tempo proprio tu che fai questo lavoro
penserete lo so È quello che mi ha
sempre detto mia madre Eppure Dopo 12
lunghi anni di studio Eccomi qua
mi sono interrogata a lungo su cosa
fosse il rumore per me e la risposta
l'ho trovata nel mio vissuto in tutti
quei momenti nei quali mi sono sentita
spesso inadeguata sperimentando un
disagio psicologico ma che cos'è l'ansia
questa espressione devo dire tanto
abusata quanto vissuta
sicuramente quello che ho sperimentato
fino a poco tempo fa e che in parte
sperimento tuttora ma in realtà da un
punto di vista psicologico si intende
per ansia uno stato di tensione che ci
separa da un evento che identifichiamo
come pericoloso che identifichiamo
attenzione
e il rumore
tutti i pensieri ad essa associati ed
associati al disagio psicologico in
generale ma sarò onesta con voi quando
parliamo di ansia non stiamo
condividendo molto di noi e del nostro
disagio perché l'ansia Come dico sempre
un'emozione ombrello sotto la quale ne
risiedono molte altre che spesso
facciamo fatica identificare e si tratta
il più delle volte di emozioni dolorose
Se c'è una cosa che mi fa spaventare del
mondo occidentale e questo Imperativo di
rimuovere il dolore No non è una mia
frase ma è quella di una canzone di
Brunori Sas che credo esprima al meglio
la condizione che tutti noi abbiamo
sperimentato almeno una volta nella vita
perché il disagio psicologico non è che
quel tentativo
di nascondere le nostre emozioni che se
trovassero accoglienza smetterebbero di
mutare indolore
un disturbo mentale può fare veramente
rumore anche se invisibile ad occhio
nudo
per alzata di mano Quanti di voi hanno
sperimentato ansia almeno una volta
nella vita inizio io
bene tutti eppure Chissà perché quando
condividevo di star sperimentando Anzi
agli amici mi veniva rimandato
puntualmente di essere quella strana
perché l'ansia e quell'emozione che
tutti sperimentano ma che poche volte
diciamo di aver provato Eppure Secondo i
dati Istat 4 milioni di persone hanno
sperimentato un disturbo ansioso
dipressivo dopo i 15 anni fino ad
arrivare ad un picco del 15 per cento
della popolazione Dopo i 65 anni
se ci fate caso le frasi che ricorrono
più spesso sono o mal di stomaco o mal
di testa o il fiato corto mi sento
stanco mal di pancia e più semplice per
gran parte della popolazione a formare
questo ma vi tolgo da ogni dubbio molto
spesso si tratta esattamente di un
disturbo psicologico solo che non siamo
allenati a riconoscerlo
non è frequente che alcuni sintomi
fisici siano erroneamente identificati
proprio come il frutto di una patologia
organica
nonostante quindi l'estrema diffusione
del disagio psicologico il feedback che
le persone ricevono E sfido tutti a dire
il contrario è così invalidante che
rinforza il loro senso di solitudine
e non è sufficiente stare in gruppo per
non sentirla quella solitudine
La solitudine diceva sempre il mio
docente di filosofia morale è un
esercizio di libertà
quando la scegliamo aggiungo io ma
l'ascolto proseguiva e la cura
Tanto nessuno mi capisce e la frase che
più spesso mi capita di ascoltare quando
le persone varcano la porta del mio
studio e quelli incomprensione quella
maledetta incomprensione rinforza il
silenzio la chiusura levitamento un
meccanismo di difesa Teso proprio a
evitare le emozioni dolorose ma
soprattutto rinforza il rumore che il
disagio fa dentro di sé
ad oggi lo stigma sulla salute mentale
nonostante gli enormi passi in avanti
fatti a partire dal periodo post
pandemico e ancora molto forte
c'è tanto da fare ma questo senso di
incomprensione vi assicuro che può
lasciare il posto a qualcosa di diverso
Forse qualcuno tra voi può immaginare a
cosa mi riferisca si tratta di un
costrutto magico
in grado di unire invece che dividere
di costruire invece che demolire sapete
di cosa parlo
dell'empatia Perché sì l'empatia viene
appresa da piccoli attraverso la
relazione con le nostre figure di
attaccamento ma la verità è che spesso
ci trinceriamo dietro l'idea
dell'empatia in quanto dote
come qualcosa che non può essere
tramandata insegnata a presa
tutti noi possiamo fare scuola di
empatia
al tempo qualcuno più autorevole di me
Carl Rodgers
sosteneva che per far sì che una
relazione funzionasse fossero necessari
tre elementi e non si riferiva solo a
quella terapeutica
empatia autenticità e accettazione
positive incondizionata
Ma cosa vuol dire fare scuola di empatia
significa insegnare alle persone a
mettersi nei panni degli altri da un
lato e insegnare chi sperimenta un
disagio psicologico ed appoggiarsi
dall'altro
vuol dire In altre parole portare il
rumore dall'interno all'esterno
dalla Profondità alla superficie
perché stare sulla superficie non vuol
dire coltivare banalità ma
esternalizzare quello che si sperimenta
prendete la vita con leggerezza dice che
Italo Calvino che leggerezza non è
superficialità ma planare sulle cose
dall'alto e non avere macigni sul cuore
solo quando il dolore viene portato in
superficie
ci si rende conto di quanto sia comune e
solo se lo si percepisce ne si apprezza
il potere trasformativo perché il
silenzio ci rende diversi
Ma la condivisione le emozioni ci
rendono uguali non abbiate paura di
condividere il vostro disagio non
abbiate paura di avere paura non c'è
coraggio senza paura avere Coraggio come
l'etimologia della parola suggerisce
vuol dire avere cuore
e così come il cuore pulsa quando
sentiamo la paura allo stesso modo fa
quando sentiamo il coraggio
siate coraggiosi
condividete il vostro dolore non siete
soli
trasformate il vostro rumore in melodia
Grazie
[Applauso]